je vous explique ken jeudi qui s'appelle
milliards à bout par les eaux qui
connaissait pas du tout je vous
expliquais j'ai fait s'appelle milla et
elle avait un mec avant d'entrer dans la
villa du chat mougeotte voilà qu'on
embrasse mouche date qui est sympathique
j'aime bien le pauvre ce qu'ils ont fait
est la pécho un mec dans la villa ils
ont fait venir son mec cool date dans la
villa après est le même mais on avait là
s'appelle naka exactement nakam ça passe
ou exactement des dossiers un haka c'est
ça votre problème c'est ça qu'on fait
alors il a vu qu'elle avait pêché un
autre mec
non parce que c'était pas encore diffusé
bah oui parce que c'est serré enregistre
à l'avant et un délit depuis combien
convoité dans la ville a regardé ses
partisans c'est qu'ils ya quelqu'un
bonsoir toujours bonjour 1 le même temps
la merde pour salut l'uda des le mec de
villas boas oloron lui bien les gars
bien le mec a misé à quoi vient lui même
de mila mais là je comprends pas les
mecs de mila c'est moi si je regarde pas
du tout comment l'amour quoi
ja lemay kabila s'est alors vu six mois
moi je vous dis la vérité après je peux
me tromper je suis persuadé qu'ils
étaient tous au courant il faut arrêter
de me prendre pour un coût de location
match déteste parce que malgré tout même
si son courant même si c'est pour jouer
même si c'est fake moi je trouve que
marié tout pour le jeune public ça
valorise l'adultère la trahison les
anges après moi j'adore les bonnes
valeurs soient ils sont tous vous le dis
très sympathique très gentil et c'est
vraiment tous des mecs bien du
nourrisson sont sympas 10 qui s'est pas
dit mais c'est pas des méchants c'est
pas des romans c'est vrai alors oui
agathe et comme bernard tu te pose
beaucoup de questions sur cette séquence
il a débarqué comme ça sur le tournage
alors invité que ce n'est pas un
candidat de télé réalité parce
qu'apparemment sami là ne lui donnez
plus du tout de nouvelles et donc il a
débarqué pour savoir ce qui se passe là
découragés
on a pu assister à la confrontation
c'était assez ou frau garde j pourquoi
d'accord pas discuter on va discuter je
suis quitter mon ex
c'est mon ex c'est mon ex dans mon ex de
mon mec c'est un peu gros a quelqu'un
ici j'ai rencontré quelqu'un y ait eu
mort est justement tu arriveras jamais
jamais jamais céder était toutefois
jeter la pierre à personne que j'ai
rencontrée dans l'épisode était
tellement attendu que même en prison
certains étaient à fond voilà je vous
dis pas ce qu'ils regardent et l'art
action voilà et regarder ses films et
audi car mon ami tout ça a été vue de
fil blanc les oiseaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc à mon avis moi je pensais que
c'était prévu mais bon ça se passe bien
et je vous dis la vérité
moi j'ai trouvé très cool mais camilla
mais il s'est vraiment marié derrière
son nom c'est vrai il s'est marié arçons
ça va ça arrive vous êtes un vieux jeu
bah ousmane barry on a pas moins de
repêchage
[Applaudissements]
non ces restitutions et la vraie vie
c'est vraiment là il me vient d alors
lui alors lui s'est aussi fait partie
des génisses et comme l'ex zaïre le mec
qui s'est marié il va seul et 30 mars
avec saluts joyeux mais je passais voix
hollande et août cette affaire donc il
est marié le gars n'a pas divorcé il a
dû divorcer
je pense que bon vous révisez ça va bien
raison c'est pas son ex et son ex point
à la ligne
non mais elle veut quand elle est dans
la danse je vais vous dire si tous les
ex de benjamin castaldi disait ça s'il
vous plaît